Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host, Ricardo Loops. And today I'm
joined by Doctor Caleb Everett, is a senior associate
in the College of Arts and Sciences at the
University of Miami and a professor in the anthropology
department with the secondary appointment in psychology. And today
we're talking about his latest book, a Myriad of
tongues. Our languages reveal differences in how we think.
So. Doctor Everett, welcome to the show. It's a
big pleasure to everyone.
Well, thanks for having me. It's great to be
here.
So, as a linguist, uh and since the book
is basically about linguistic diversity and our languages are
so diverse in many different kinds of aspects and
we'll get into some of those aspects. But I
would like to start by asking you, do you
think that in linguistics, particularly nowadays, people still tend
to assume too much universality in language?
Yeah, I would say so. And that's one of
the cases made in the book and I'm not
the only one making that case to be clear
these days. Um There, there's been an assumption of
that. At least some features of languages are universal.
And I think increasingly that argument is, is harder
to support. Basically, as linguists have done more research
in different parts of the world um with different
populations that are not western, educated, industrialized, rich democracies,
these so called weird societies. And as the focus
of linguistic research has been less European or indo-european,
let's say, um I think that the the evidence
for universals in, in language are, are really uh
harder and harder. The evidence is harder and harder
to come by. There are still some who think
that there are some core tenets of language that
are universal. I'm not one of those folks. Um
There are some reasonable arguments, I just think it's
harder and harder to support. And as I said,
there are a number of linguists that have been
making this case now for a while and this
book helps to synthesize some of the work of
those scholars.
But when it comes to the differences, we find
across languages, I mean, of course, this is a
very broad question but where would you say those
differences stem from primarily?
I mean, that's a good question. So some of
the things relate to say, just the different usage
of function of the functional usage of certain linguistic
forms in certain contexts, right? So you can think
of something like like my last book was about
numbers and number words and things like that. And
it's clear that there are pressures on cultures in
certain contexts to develop number words more than in
other contexts, right? It's not that one is better
or worse. It's just that there are pressures in
certain contexts to develop certain features of certain linguistic
features. Some of it is a lot more analogous
to what we might think of as genetic drift,
right? Where it's just there are differences that crop
up in populations. When you have thousands of populations
living around the world, there are going to be
certain differences in speech and in cultural norms that
develop that maybe have no like clear motivation, they
just are differences, right? And that, that's a big
part of you get these, you know, probabilistic tendencies
across languages and then you and these are gonna
just operate in different ways in different contexts. So
those, those are part of the reasons for the
differences. Another potential reason for some of the differences
are uh environmental differences, right? So some of this
might be really obvious, like if you're, if you're
a hunter gather group in Amazonia, you might have
a greater need to distinguish certain um flora and
fauna around you in more precise ways than say
I would, right. So, you know, um for instance,
some of the people that I've worked with in,
in the Amazon, um the Kiana, they have a
variety of different words for, for monkey species. Um
But there's no like sort of super ordinate term
of monkey because that's less of a useful feet,
like it's very important for them to break things
down into the individual. Whereas for, for me, even
though I know there are lots of terms for
these species in English, I don't know them. Right.
So I call a lot of, I have like
a few different terms for monkey. Now, that's something
that's clearly impacted in one way or another by
the environment. So you get this collage of motivations
for why languages differ, those, those are a few
of them anyway.
And another one of those reasons has to do
with uh people's specific social needs. Correct?
Yeah. So social units, so like the kind of
um kinship terms that they have, you know, this,
this, this reflects, you know, critical differences in, in
terms of how the social units are constructed within
societies. There's some research suggesting that um you know,
languages spoken by larger populations have some differences, some
tendencies in contrast to languages spoken by very small
populations. Um That's something that's hotly debated amongst linguists
and amongst other cognitive scientists. But yeah, there do
seem to be, there is some evidence that um
varying social pressures across groups impact how languages evolve.
So let's get into a few concrete examples here
in the book, you talk about time, for example.
So what do we know about how people think
about time and what relationship does that have with
uh language?
Yeah, that's a really good question. So when you,
when I I mean, I'll give you an anecdote,
like when I, when I teach um a linguistics
course here at the University of Miami, and I
ask students how you think about time and they'll,
they'll often start talking about past, present and future
as though these are sort of, you know, immutable
categories that exist. And obviously, in some ways, we
all experience time. You know, the claim in the
book is not that the language you speak totally
changes your perception of time passing itself. But it
comes as a surprise to some students, to most
students that many languages don't have three tenses. You
know, many languages have only two tenses, some languages
have no tenses, some languages have as many as
seven tenses. And so this this reflects the fact
that that how we delineate time linguistically can vary
sometimes more than people realize, right, whether that has
any effect on how people think about time when
it comes to tense less clear. Um But there
are some other examples of the way that we
talk about time that seem to indicate that there
are these associated differences in how people think about
time. So the common metaphor of the the past
being behind you and the future being in front
of you. That's not something that we have in
English and that exists in a number of languages
around the world. That's not a metaphor that exists
in all the world's languages, right? So in many
languages, some talked about in the book, you talk
about the past as though it is in front
of you. And the future is though it's behind
you. And researchers that have, have studied these groups
have shown, for instance that when they're talking about
the past, they oftentimes point in front of themselves,
right? Whereas in English, when we talk about the
past, we tend to point backwards, right? So this
seems to reflect these gestures seem to reflect some
wider cognitive processes that are, that are sort of
being indicated by the the metaphors that we use.
Or you could say that the metaphors themselves are
somehow impacting how we think about the passing of
time. One of the really fascinating examples in the
book is from a group of people called the
Eno in New Guinea. And this is research done
by other folks at the University of California, San
Diego and other places showing that in that language,
they tend to talk about the time is flowing
uphill, you know, so whether you point in front
of you or behind you depends on which way
you're facing on a hill at the time that
you're talking. And you can imagine that if you're
trying to learn that language, as you say, an
anthropological linguist, trying to figure that out, it must
be really tricky to figure that out, right? But
then you talk to someone who speaks a language
like that and it might seem very natural to
them. I think that's one of the interesting things
is that these ways of talking about time and
gesturing about time come to seem very natural as
though it's like just the default human experience. When
in reality it clearly isn't. There's some, there's more
variability there than, than people often realize.
So, since you've done work on numbers does the
way we talk about time connect in any way
to the way we talk about numbers. I I'm
asking you that also because I mean, at least
in more Western languages, I, I'm not sure about
the universality of this or not, but we tend
also to subdivide time in terms of hours, minutes,
seconds, I mean, count basically the passage of time
in that way. So uh is there some connection
there? Yeah,
I think so. I mean, I think it's, it's
almost hard to overstate what a difference that makes,
right? So if you talk about, um there was
some research done with an Amazonian group about 10
years ago. The Tupi kawa is the name of
the language anyway. And this is not that far
from where I've done some of my research in
the Amazon. And there's not any evidence that they
talk about time and hardly at all right. There's
really not much concrete evidence of that and they
don't seem to use the metaphors for time, any
of the metaphors that I just mentioned, like future
being in front of you past being behind you.
So you can imagine that in a group like
that when there aren't many words that are associated
with things related to time, of course, that doesn't
mean people aren't experiencing time in that group. But
the point is that they don't have words for
things like week or month or, or, um, season
perhaps. But in a context like that, you can
think about how foreign, something like hours and minutes
and seconds seconds are, right. And these sort of
linguistic units pretty much govern our lives, right? Like
everything about our lives is constrained by hours and
minutes and seconds. And if you think about the
origins of these terms, they're very much related to
the numerical systems of other languages, some of which
are now extinct, right? So if you the base
60 system, you know, 60 minutes, 60 seconds that
comes from really can be traced back to Ancient
Mesopotamia where there was a base 60 number system.
And then that influenced the tracking of time in
different places, including Ancient Greece and then made its
way into Europe, right? Um, IN terms of 12
hours, that's something that goes back to Egyptian sun
dials thousands of years ago where they had 10
units for the sun dial for dividing the day
up and then they added a unit for dawn
and a unit for dusk. You know, when the
light, when the sun's not completely up, but it's
light out and then, so that's how you get
12, right? And then if you do that at
night too, eventually we had the people had the
idea to divide the night up into equal units
also. So you can see how you go when
you count hours and minutes, you're going from something
that's influenced by Ancient Egyptian sundials to ancient Mesopotamian
number systems to then the decimal number system that
we all take for granted. So you're kind of
as you tell time, you're kind of taking a
trip through time through these different eras. And so
this is kind of all this cultural residue that
has been, you know, acquired in our, in our
uh tracking of time. But we learn it, we
take it for granted and obviously, it affects how
we think in some level because we're constantly thinking
about hours and minutes and seconds and how much
longer do we have before the next meeting or
whatever? It very much governs our lives. So, so,
yeah, I think it's, it's fair to say that
there's some influence of thought uh based on our
number systems on how we think about time.
Uh So when it comes to numbers, uh if
what I'm about to say is outdated, please correct
me. But uh I read some time ago that
at least in more traditional societies like hunter gatherers,
horticulturalists and so on that when it comes to
counting, people usually count up to three, sometimes five
and then they just use words like our terms
like, uh, a few, many a lot. And so
it's just in societies where we have really formal
schooling that we count beyond, beyond three or five.
I mean, is that true? I mean,
yeah, that's, that's not an inaccurate generalization. I mean,
it's definitely a general, there are exceptions. Right. There
are plenty of, um, hunter gatherer groups, especially one
of the things about number systems is they spread
very quickly, right? Like people tend to see how
useful they are or they have economic pressures to
get to know numbers so that they're not taken
advantage of. And so they can sort of spread
like this cognitive fire. But it is true that
there are some very simple number systems in hunter
gatherer groups where there doesn't seem to be a
lot of usefulness maybe to number systems in ways
that there might be for us. And obviously, it's
not because these people are incapable of learning numbers.
It's just that they haven't developed in their society.
A famous case is, um the PETA Ha in
the Amazon. This is a group I've spent some
time with the work of my father made this
group famous. Um, BUT they have basically no numbers
at all, no precise numbers. And some cognitive scientists
um went from Berkeley and mit went down there
and sort of helped demonstrate this experimentally. So that's
one that's an extreme case. There seemed to be
maybe a couple of cases like that worldwide where
there's no precise number of words at all in
a group. What's more common is what you're talking
about a, a 12 mini system or a 123
mini system or some groups that do have elaborate
number systems, but maybe they're just not used as
frequently. So, um I worked with this one group
but this was over 10 years ago. Um THAT
had number words that it was thought that they
didn't have number words when I did some experiments
with them, it was clear that they do have
number words, but it wasn't clear how many people
in the culture knew them. Right. So, some of
the, some of the older men that I talked
to seem to know the number system that they
had used when, when hunting or talking about how
long they were going to be gone on a
hunting trip. But I think that's another factor is
how, how, how diffuse are the numbers within a
society for, for societies like ours because you're sort
of, they're inculcated in us from a really young
age, like you're just taught numbers. And again, it's
another thing that just comes to seem to be
like a default way of how the world works.
And we don't realize that these are actually sort
of culturally specific things that we're acquiring as, as
we're raised in a numerate culture.
Mhm. So, we've sort of already made reference to
this. But, uh, when we talked about, for example,
how certain people tend to think about, uh, time,
uh, uh, uh, if we're talking about the past
back then or in front of them or something
like that. So there's already somewhat of a rela,
uh, of a relationship between time and space there.
But looking across languages, I mean, how much really
is there of a relationship between how we talk
about time and how we talk about space?
I mean, that's a really good question. Um Another
thing that's been debated, but it's pretty clear that
cultures in general make use of space to talk
about time, right? Time is this really abstract thing,
we can't reach out and touch it. It's not
like around us. And so mapping time onto space,
which is more concrete and we can talk about
it as being in front of us or it
helps us make sense of this very nebulous thing
of the passing of time, right? Even as I
say that I'm saying, the passing of time and
obviously that's a spatial thing too, like time is
not really passing. And so there have been some
suggestions that every culture, they may talk about time
in terms of space in different ways, like the
examples I gave before. But every culture talks about
time in terms of space somehow. But there again
that there's been suggestions that that is not a
universal, it's just a tendency because we seem to,
for everything that we say, oh, this is a
universal of how people talk. Inevitably someone will come
back and say now I've been working with this
group for, you know, 10 years and I swear
they don't do that. You know, it's like, it's
more of a sampling problem than anything. There, there
could be that certainly does seem to be a
very strong tendency though, across human populations. People like
to make sense of time in terms of space.
Another very interesting thing related to space is how
we use directions. Like for example, we in our
western languages tend to use left and right. But
there are other languages where people actually use cardinal
orientations like east and west. So do we know
exactly why there are those differences?
I mean, that's a good, that's another great question.
I think in terms of why the differences exist,
it's, it's always easy to debate, right? We can
come up with different ideas like, so what you're
talking about in terms of egocentric directions, right, based
on the body, like left versus right, these very
common worldwide. And it's another thing that at some
point people said, well, this is just a universal
humans think about space in terms of centered around
their body. And so they're always going to describe
things as being, they're going to use some egocentric
system. It may not be left versus right, but
it's going to be something like that. And then
inevitably, it turns out there are plenty of groups
that don't do that. So some of them are
more geocentric which, you know, centered around features of
the earth or this could be something like, you
know, like you said, cardinal directions like east versus
west, north versus south. And then it turns out
there are plenty of groups where it might not
exactly be those directions, but the way that they
give spatial reference, the way that they talk about
spatial references or give directions tend to be geocentric.
It's not left versus right, it's not centered on
the human body. And so there the differences in
spatial uh terminology and how people refer to the
space around themselves turns out are much greater than
people once thought back in the say seventies and
eighties. And basically, since the nineties, there's been increasing
research showing that people think about space and really
diverse ways now why those differences exist? That's, you
know, we can debate how much of that is
just like what I said earlier, something analogous to
genetic drift where it's just like people are going
to do things differently in different contexts. They just,
I think there are some some ways of talking
about space that are clearly more likely to develop
in certain areas. So like things that are centered
around the sun, right? Or where are probably more
like there's going to be some bias towards like
equatorial sunny regions, right? Where east tends to be
in a clear direction and west tends to be
in the clear direction. You can imagine why that
might be less likely to develop in high latitudes
or something like that where east and west aren't
so, so obvious. Um But you know, these, these
environmental effects seem to be subtle and they're not
deterministic, like we can't just say, oh, this, this
language is spoken here and so the people probably
talk about space this way, right? Um There are
a number of cultures though where they talk about
directions in terms of uphill or downhill, you know,
in a certain plane. And it's not necessarily the
immediate hill that they're on, but it's the general
trajectory of the geography and the surrounding terrain. And
obviously, you wouldn't develop a system like that if
you just live in the plains of North America
or something like that where there aren't a lot
of hills like that, that's pretty clear that there's
some environmental influence. How much is a matter of,
of debate.
So we earlier, we've already touched a little bit
on how languages also influence in a way how
we understand and talk about social relationships. And you
mentioned kinship systems, for example, but it also applies
to things like social groups and classes, race, ethnicity,
gender and so on.
Yeah. Yeah, it, it relates to everything. And so
some of the terms, I mean, gender is a
good one, right? Where there are some languages that
have maybe a, a term for a generic third
gender and a lot of languages. It's just binary.
Um IN terms of kinship, there, I go into
a few of these things in the books, but
there are entire volumes dedicated to differences in kinship
terms because they can be very extreme, right? So
whether or not um like one feature that I
think is interesting because I've come across it in
some of my own work is age differences in
kinship, right? So in the example of the Carico,
where you have differences between that brother and sister,
there's no term, just brother or sister, the the
term sister, like there's a term for older sister,
there's a term for younger sister, but you're always
kind of referencing your age and relationship to the
people around you in your kinship network. And that
kind of, you know, reciprocity of reference to age
is something that we're not that familiar with. It
can feel a little bit strange, but, you know,
after you spend enough time talking to people like
that, that these are clearly very important aspects of
their, of their kinship system. And so I think
that's kind of the interesting thing is that people
have different kinship systems, they have very different terms
for the different, you know, nodes within that kinship
system. And then this kind of reinforces certain way
of thinking about relationships.
Mhm. Uh In the book, you also get a
little bit into how we talk about colors and
smells and uh how that influences how we remember
visual and olfactory stimuli. So, could you tell us
a bit about that?
Yeah. So this is research that goes back decades
now. Um It's, it's been evolving over the last
few decades, let's say. So. Um THERE, there have
been these surveys done starting with color terms. Um
uh Berlin and k these two scholars, they did
this, they did this influential book um over, I
guess it's been about 50 years now and they
demonstrating the differences in color terms across a lot
of the world's languages. And the basic way that
this works is um researchers in different places give
uh paint chips, color chips to different groups and
have them name them, you know, a whole array
of different hues and see where do they break
up color terms? Are there differences across languages in
terms of how the hues are broken up? And
it turns out there are actually a lot of
differences and there are a lot of differences in
terms of the number of terms that, that uh
languages have so called basic color words. There are
some suggestions that some languages don't really have basic
color words. But setting that aside, most languages have
somewhere between three and 11, basic color terms. So
there's a lot of variation, but then there still
are some tendencies, which is really maybe not too
surprising because we all have the same visual apparatus,
we're all seeing the world in, in roughly the
same way. However, there is some evidence that the
some of the languages color term distinctions impact in
subtle ways how people think about colors, or at
least how they group them in certain cognitive tasks
and their, their capacity to recall certain color terms.
So if you, if your language makes, it makes
a color term distinction between blue and green, for
instance, which many languages do not. Um There's evidence
that when you perceive um colors stimuli that that
are on different sides of that border blue versus
green, you're more likely to recall that difference in
some experimental tasks, right? So no one makes the
claim that like these are huge differences, right? A
lot of these things can get distorted, these are
probably fairly minor differences. Um BUT it's still interesting,
right? Because it suggests that the language that you
speak impacts in subtle ways how you perform on
certain visual tasks, right?
Uh But uh I mean, that's about basically recalling
certain callers and smells, for example, but do, do
we know if language actually influences what people see
and smell? Is that something that happens or not?
I
mean, there is some research on this, I I
don't how they see and how they smell is
maybe too strongly worded, but I do think some
of the results are surprising, right? So that there's
some evidence that like being presented with um verbal
stimuli impacts the likelihood that you're going to discriminate
certain colors in a visual task, right? Um So,
and you know, and then obviously, if your language
doesn't have those words as verbal stimuli, maybe that
affects how you do in certain visual tasks. But
I, and, and there, by the way, there is
a bunch of research now coming out suggesting that
words for smells vary more radically across cultures than
we once thought. And that some cultures have abstract
odor terms that are more analogous to our abstract
color terms. You know, for instance, in English instance
in English, we don't really have abstract odor terms
to the extent that some of these other languages
now seem we we're seeing that they do have
whether that actually impacts how you smell, you know,
that's a different question, but there's some evidence. But
I would say that it's that the, you know,
it's not like huge. I I never want to
give like when I'm talking about this stuff in
class, I never want to give students the impression
that like it just changes how you see completely.
I think that kind of view was romanticized way
too much and it as a result, it made
some um scholars more skeptical of any differences, right,
that there's any differences in thought based on language
and the the claims these days are more subtle
than that. Yeah, but yes, there, there do seem
to be some effects. It's just the size of
those effects is, is debatable.
Yeah, I, I ask you, I asked you that
because actually, I mean, perhaps a while ago there
was a period of time where certain people were
claiming or almost claiming. Actually that perhaps the way
we talk, the words we used to refer to
colors, actually, it changed our visual system when it
came to how we process colors and we would
be able to identify some and completely miss others
or something like that. But perhaps that's too strong,
it might be too strong. But I, I don't
wanna, I don't wanna be dismissive of all that
work either because I do think there's some really
careful experimental work showing. So I'll give you an
example of a study. I don't know if I
talk about this in this book, but like, you
know, research showing that people are better at discriminating
certain colors presented to the right visual field, which
is processed by the left hemisphere where most of
our language processing typically happens. And they show that
the color discrimination differs for the right visual field
depending on the color terms that you have in
your language, right? So that is an example of
sort of an effect on how people are actually
immediately discriminating colors, right? So that's so I, I
don't want to give the impression that there's no
evidence for any of this stuff. It's just sometimes
people get the sense that like, oh you just
in the popular media, maybe the the uptake of
some of that work sometimes is just oversimplified to
the point that it seems like if you don't
speak a language with green and blue distinctions, you're
really just not gonna, everything's just gonna be collapsed
visually and that's not what the research suggests, but
there do seem to be some effects.
So earlier, we've also mentioned briefly how the physical
environment can influence our particular languages evolve. And in
the book, you go through the example of extreme
ambient aridity. So ho how does that particular kind
of environment influence our languages or particular languages have
evolved?
Um Yeah, that's a, that's probably of the research
I've done. That's the most hotly contested research, right?
Because um whenever you suggest environmental influences on language,
it turns out there's there's some things that make
people uncomfortable about that, I think. Um BUT I
would argue that that's actually almost a boring thing,
right? Like where there's plenty of research in the
lab showing that really dry air affects how the
vocal cords operate, right? That's not controversial. That's in
fact well established and you kind of know this
from personal experience, right? Like even if you spend
a couple of days in the desert, not drinking
too much, um you can sort of see effects
on your vocal cords. Now, the question is, does
that kind of thing impact how languages evolve? And
so I had this paper with um uh two
colleagues of mine, uh Damian Blasi and Sean Roberts.
This was quite a while now ago now um
in the proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences,
and we suggested that in really dry places, um
complex tones which require precision of the vocal cords
might be less likely to evolve. This was one
of those things that got caught by the media
and I would say really oversimplified by the media.
And so it, it created, that was part of
what created some of the headaches, right? Was that
people they the uptake seemed to be that we
were suggesting that wherever the language is spoken, you
could predict whether it's tonal or not. And we
weren't even suggesting a broad association between humidity and,
and complex tones. We were just saying, hey, in
really dry places, maybe it's less likely that they
would evolve, given this research in the lab on
how the vocal cords work. And then we showed
a lot of data cross linguistically across the thousands
of languages that seem consistent with that, but it's
ultimately correlational. So you can debate it whether or
not that's actually, and it's been hotly debated since
then. Basically, there was, I should say a really
cool study um by some Chinese scholars this year
after my book was already off to press that
offered, I think even better evidence for this than
we did. Because one of the things they these
Chinese scholars did was they looked at a million
actual audio files um by people that these audio
files were recorded all over China. And what they
found was that in really dry places, you can
see even in natural speech outside the lab that
there's an effect of dry air on the precision
with which the vocal cords vibrate. So that doesn't
mean that we were definitely on the right track,
but it's suggestive that, you know, at least in
that case, there does seem to be ambient influence
on how the vocal cords operate which again, and
I don't find that uh particularly shocking or surprising,
but it uh I have to be honest and
say it's still very hotly debated,
you know, when it comes to en environment to
the influence of the environment. One thing that I
got across a few years ago that really fascinated
me was uh the existence of whistled languages, like
for example, in Greece, in mountainous places, there are
uh a few communities where people in instead of
really actually talking, they whistle to one another because
I mean, they are very far apart because of
the mountainous terrain and all of that. And so
it's easier for them to convey information by whistling
than by just talking to each other. And uh
there are actual whistled languages or whistled versions of
languages.
Yeah, there are. And you, you're, you're absolutely right
that they tend to be. There are some in
some dense jungle regions in, in Amazonia even. But
there is this tendency for them to be in
mountainous terrain in Turkey, in Greece, in, um, Canary
Islands in Central America. And so one plausible interpretation
is the one that you just gave, right, you
can see people at great distances in these places,
but you can't really communicate in the absence of
these whistled frequencies that allow you to communicate. Right.
That's a clear and I think that's less controversial.
However, it also gets at what's tricky about some
of these hypotheses, which is that at the end
of the day, it's a very small number of
data points. So it's hard to say, to establish
definitively that that's why, you know, because there are
always exceptions, languages that are spoken in the dense
Amazon or something like that and aren't in the
same places. But yeah, I think it's totally reasonable
interpretation.
So another thing that, that I would like to
ask you about here is do you think that
there might be some issues when we try to
study grammatical patterns in sort of idealized and written
sentences? Because it might not really be representative of
the ways people normally use uh language?
No, I think that's, that's 100% accurate and that,
that's something that, you know, those of us who
have done field research. I mean, these days, a
lot of my research is at a computer with
databases or whatever or even in a lab. But
the field research in some ways is the hardest
work I've ever done because you're in this place
where you're, you're trying to learn another language. But
what you have to go on a lot of
times are idealized, sort of simple clauses that you're
trying to learn and you can, without intention, you
know, unintentionally, sometimes you can project a certain kind
of structure on the language that you're learning, right?
Because you're, even if you're a well trained linguist,
you bring in all these biases of the things
you want to learn of the kinds of structures
you expect to find. And so you're asking them,
how do you say this, how do you say
that? And we're aware of these things? And people
will say, well, that's not how you really should
do it, but it's really hard to do it
any other way because life is too short, you
know, like what's the best way? Well, maybe the
best way is to go spend 20 years with
an indigenous group without bringing your biases and just
try to absorb the language around you and sort
of pay attention to what's more frequent and what's
less frequent. That's pretty much impossible for an academic
career, right? So what you find and this is
alluded to in the book is a lot of
the very best research in my opinion on indigenous
languages comes from missionaries and that's not something we're
always comfortable talking about in academia, but the truth
is, some of them don't do very good work.
Some of them are the only people who have
actually spent decades living with the group and sort
of learning the language to the point that they
can say, you know, during my first two years,
I thought this was how the language works. And
then I found out 10 years later that's not
at all how it works. Right. But that takes
a lot of time. I think that you're totally
right though, in terms of some of the issues,
we bring methodologically what would be useful in some
ways is what we need is what we are
using now in languages like English that inform a
chat GP T huge large language models that are
based on just millions of clauses of data. We
just don't, we're not in a position to get
that level of data from indigenous languages. But maybe
we will be someday, you know, we'll be able
to just record data in massive amounts and be
able to figure out patterns in the data through
um in part through A I and other tools.
Yeah, maybe someday just uh doing some audio recording
of people just naturally talking and then uh through
A I translating that into text and then analyzing
it or something like
that. Yeah, it's tough when there's not any, you
know, A I is not going on anything, there's
nothing already available on that language. But yes, you
can see how things might improve in that way.
Um TO be fair. A lot of field linguists
these days, they do record a lot of data,
but then still they have to go through that
data very time consuming. And so, you know, creating
digital corpora of data that they can just analyze
maybe more objectively. That's, that's still very, very time
consuming.
So another very interesting question in linguistics is, are,
are words arbitrary? That is uh uh I mean,
are there any patterns in terms of certain meanings
tended to be to go associated with certain specific
sounds or even words? I mean, is that something
that occurs or are just words basically arbitrary and
any word can mean basically anything?
Yeah, I mean, I think most words probably are
arbitrary and can mean anything. And that's been the
standard line in linguistics research for a while. But
increasingly, I would say, especially over the last 10
years, there's been AAA growing number of studies showing
that more words, words are less arbitrary than we
thought, right? Or at least some words are less
arbitrary than we thought. So there are these systematic
correspondences between sounds and meanings across the world's culture.
So, one of the best studies I know about
this was done by that same colleague I mentioned
earlier, Damian Blasi, where they, he and the team
looked at thousands of languages and they found some
clear associations between certain sounds and certain meanings even
after controlling for a bunch of particular uh influences.
Um So like one example that I'm, if I
recall correctly is um, the word for nose tends
to have a nasal sound in it. So something
like nah, and you can sort of see why
that might be the case, right? When you have
produce a nasal sound frequencies resonate in the nasal
cavity. And so maybe that makes it more perceptually
salient. What was really interesting about that study is
that there are obviously thousands of exceptions, right? It's,
it's these very subtle tendencies that we, there's no
way we could have noticed, you know, say 20
years ago. But as these databases have come online
and as they're being refined, we're starting to be
able to ask these questions in new ways and
test them in new ways. Things like uh is
a sound system impacted by the environment, maybe not.
But we could never really even ask and test
that question before. Are, are this, are languages, are
the words of languages maybe more um systematic in
terms of how they map sounds and meanings than
we once thought. Well, maybe, but we could never
have tested this, you know, say 20 years ago.
So it's requiring new methods, new databases to, to
maybe change our perspectives on some of these topics
and language research.
And do we have any idea if there are
sort of basic words that occur in uh virtually
all languages,
you just to be clear, do you mean semantics
like in terms of content, like the word meaning
like the word? Yeah, I mean there there have
been some suggestions of this, right? But it's um
so number words have been one of those suggestions,
right? That was one of the ones that at
some point people said, OK, language is made different
in terms of how many number words they have
but every language has some precise word for one
and two turns out that doesn't seem to be
the case. Although the vast majority do same with
color terms that used to be thought to be
universal, you know, not so clear anymore. Same with
something like the word for mother. You know, I
increasingly there was this influential article by two linguists
uh Nick Evans and Steven Levinson. This was over
10 years ago now, were entitled The Myth of
Language Universals. And, and they went through some of
these examples showing a lot of these words that
we thought were at least universal. Even these. There,
there always seems to be an exception somewhere, but
there's very strong tendencies, right? So like it's, it's
pretty much guaranteed that a language is gonna have,
you know, pick a language at random that it's
gonna have a word for the concept one for
instance.
Uh And so I've asked you about uh some
of the issues with having to actually have idealized
and written form of a particular language to study
it uh is it really possible to accurately translate
every word and expression?
Yeah, I would say um I would say not,
right. And again, this is going to depend on
how closely related the languages are, how closely related
the cultures are. But I think that we've, even
if you speak two European languages as you do,
at least that many, right? Or like I grew
up in Brazil, I speak is a lot better
than I speak any Amazonian language. Even between Portuguese
and English. I find sometimes that, that there's a
little bit of loss in the translation, right? There's,
there's some cultural nuance that's maybe missed as someone
translates something into this language. You know that I
like the example of the movie Lost in translation.
You know that the movie entitled Lost in translation
with Bill Murray that was titled very differently in
a lot of different cultures because the expression lost
in translation itself can get lost in translation, right?
It's really hard to have it. Now. That's not
to say that nothing is perfectly translatable. It's just
that a lot of times we're trans translating things
that are maybe almost perfectly translatable, but something is
getting missed. There's some cultural nuance that's not being
conveyed by a phrase in one language uh as
it's translated into another.
Now that that's very interesting also because even when
it comes to Portuguese itself, because we have different
versions of Portuguese, like Brazilian, Portuguese and European Portuguese
sometimes since you mentioned lost in translation, the movie,
it came to my mind that sometimes for the
same movie, there are two different titles in Brazil
and in Portugal. And one of them is better
suited for a Brazilian audience because it combines the
meaning better. And the other one is better suited
for a Portuguese audience even though it's almost the
same language.
Yeah, that's a good point because then you're talking
about what, well, essentially dialects of the same language.
Um Although anecdotally, I almost find Spanish easier to
understand than when I'm in Portugal to, you know,
because of the you guys uh from my perspective
as someone who grew up in Brazil, you're dropping
vowels all over the place, you know, but it's,
but I, I love the sound of Brazilian Portuguese.
But yeah, it's clearly, even though it's technically, you
know, I mean, I love the sound of European,
Portuguese even though there's clearly different dialects, European. And
so if that can happen, even within two dialects
is my point, then imagine what can happen when
you get to very unrelated languages. Take something like
um Kiana, the language that I mentioned and then
pick some, you know, language in Australia or Eastern
China or wherever you want to pick, there's going
to be all kinds of things that, that are
lost related to the environments of these different places
related to the cultural context. That doesn't mean you
can't translate it all of course, people do it.
But it means that there, the idea of perfect
translation may be a myth at least when you're
going between certain languages.
So I have perhaps two more questions here. One
of them, since your book is basically about linguistic
diversity and how uh for example, social relationships or
our society is structured and the environment that we
are exposed to influence our particular languages evolve. And
also how by using particular words, terms and languages,
it also influences how we perceive the world in
at least to a certain extent. What are your
thoughts on the word hypothesis?
Yeah. So Super War warf hypothesis is interesting in
part because Super and Wharf never actually co-authored anything.
It's not like they sat down that term always
makes it seem like they sat down and wrote
some hypothesis out, you know, and like really work.
But it was really um war's work um amongst
the Hopi tribe in the in the United States
that, that gave this a lot of impetus and
the idea is related to things like how they
talk about time and some of his suggestions haven't
really, you know, stood the test of time. But
I think that the general point that that is
sometimes referred to by superior war hypothesis may be
accurate in the sense that languages do impact cognitive
processes, like linguistic diversity does impact cognitive processes, but
these impacts can be pretty subtle. Um So I
think the way that it's commonly construed as is
maybe off, right, like Super Wharf is sometimes taken
as, oh, like you speak a different language, you
know, say you speak KPI, you really just don't
get the passing of time or anything. Like it's
just a totally different, you're living a more centered
existence or something like that. And that was never
what Super or Wharf meant in the first place.
Um So it's, it's kind of that the, the
issue with that the the label Super Wharf is
that it's come to mean all these different things
that I don't think even Wharf meant it to
mean, right? Um The, the the example that I
start the book off with kind of tongue in
cheek is the words for Snow example, right? Where
that's something that like is associated with the Super
Wharf hypothesis. But these, it, it it actually goes
back to the work of some other linguists. Even
Franz Boas was the first one who really pointed
out like these different words for Snow and different
indigenous groups that they maybe had more. But he
never said anything about there being hundreds of words
for Snow and Eskimo or you know, like, and
you can see the cycle of exaggeration that that
this claim is tied to like and some of
it's in the media. So I think even at
one point, the New York Times had some quote
about there are hundreds of words for Snow and
in Eskimo, which is just not true, it's just
patently untrue. And so part of the issue with
the Super War warf hypothesis is that it has
about a century's worth of baggage. Now that's been
carried through the media in different places and it's
distorted, was maybe inaccurate in some places. But at
the end of the day, a fairly reasonable points
made by, by Wharf and then kind of distorted
them. And it took research in the nineties and
in the last 30 years to address this topic
um in more subtle ways and actually get at
this idea of do different do linguistic disparities actually
impact human cognitive processes and, and, and the answer
is yes, although sometimes the answer is a subtle
one and sometimes the answer seems to be no,
you know, we expect to find some difference but
you do some experimental tests and there don't really
seem to be any differences across populations in terms
of how they, they think about a given thing.
So that less exciting than like, oh, it determines
how you think or no, it doesn't determine how
you think, you know, the answers are often in
the gray areas. I think.
So, one last question then, um since we've been
talking about the diversity of language, I would also
like to ask you if you have any idea
if this is sort of representative or illustrative or
one small example of a broader discussion that is
sort of ongoing in psychology and cognitive science, I
guess about the universality of our psychology more broadly
in terms of, if we really across all societies
share the same uh information processing mechanisms or mechanisms
or not, I mean, do, do you think that
this perhaps might play a role in that sort
of discussion or a and if so do you
think that perhaps we uh we might also be
assuming at least in certain instances too much universality
when it comes to human cognition or not?
I think so, it depends on who you talk
to, right? So some people now assume less universality.
I have really close colleagues who are evolutionary psychologists
and I actually find a lot of that work
pretty stimulating. I don't agree with all of it,
but they're sort of interested in what are the,
what are the processes, the evolutionary processes that may
maybe gave humans certain biases to think about things
in certain ways that would have presented selective advantages.
That's a totally reasonable thing to think about. Um
On the other hand, you know, we only left
Africa in waves as a species like 100,000 years
ago. That's not a lot of time, right? In
terms of so those kinds of pressures are probably
applied to all cultures, right? Like I, I would
guess I would guess that there's not a lot
that's hardwired about us that's different. Um But that
doesn't mean that it's universally, that universality is the
answer, right? Because the main thing, it seems to
me reading into some of these fields is that
the the overarching theme is that uh cortical plasticity,
right? We're just this like incredibly adaptive species and
we do seem to do things that are kind
of unique, like pay attention to the intentions of
other members of our species and we're clearly more
social. Um But so the answer is just like
sort of this clear plasticity, which allows for a
lot of variability across groups in terms of how
we problem solve. And in terms of how we,
how we see the world in some ways. But
that I guess my point is that I don't
think that that's necessarily hardwired in us. I think
what's hardwired is this sort of a general flexibility
of cognition um which allows us to confront all
sorts of challenges in unique ways and then maybe
those are affected by culture and language over time
so that you get very different ways of addressing
certain problems in the world around us based on
the cultural and linguistic lineage that you're familiar with.
Yes, because even though perhaps there's no been enough
time since we left Africa for us to be
to have acquired, let's say new cognitive adaptations through
genetic evolution, we also have cultural evolution, for example.
Right. Yes, exactly. And that's ultimately a lot of
this book is indirectly about cultural evolution, right? Like
things people adapt to different places and sometimes it's
actually clearly an adaptive process. Sometimes it's just a
matter of, like I said, it's more an analogous
to genetic drift where there's lots of different cultures,
people doing different things, some things are going to
succeed in some environments, some things are just going
to be different just because they're different. But we
can clearly change a lot over a short amount
of time. Right. And so I don't want to
trivialize that point. So like if you take something
like literacy, writing has only been around about 5000
years, that's like nothing in terms of our trajectory
as a species. And until the last couple 100
years and really the last 100 years, the vast
majority of people even in the West were, were
not literate, right? And so, and there's plenty of
research showing that learning how to read and write
and learning math at an early age has certain
neural cognitive effects um that that you can detect
in lots of different ways. And so these are
profound, these can be profound effects that sort of
differences cross culturally. So even if we start off
with a general sort of plasticity that we all
share, that doesn't mean that the effects are trivial,
right? Cross culturally
great. So the book is again, a myriad of
tongues, our languages reveal differences in how we think
I'm leaving a link to it in the description
box of the interview. And Dr Everett just before
we go apart from the book, we would like
to tell people where they can find your work
on the internet.
Oh, yeah, working. So my previous book is um
Numbers in the making of us. So if you
just Google that you can find that also and
it addresses similar concept of human diversity, but with
respect to number systems and how they evolved, I
have another book but it's more sort of academic
in nature. So maybe less interesting of a read.
Um But yeah, Google, my name and the research
and, and, and you, and you'll find it. But
um yeah, I'm excited about this book and it
was great to talk to you about it. Ricardo,
I appreciate your great questions.
No, thank you so much for taking the time
to come on the show. It's been great to
talk to you. Ok.
Awesome.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you liked it, please share it.
Leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by N Lights Learning
and development. Then differently check the website at N
lights.com and also please consider supporting the show on
Patreon or paypal. I would also like to give
a huge thank you to my main patrons and
paypal supporters, Perego Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno
Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam Kel Matthew Whitten.
Be no wt ho Ealj con Phil for Con.
Then the Met Robert Wine in NAI Z Mark
Nevs calling Hol Brookfield, Governor Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre
Francis for Agns Ferus and H her meal and
Lain Jung Y and the Samuel K Hes Mark
Smith J Tom Hummel S David Sloan Wilson Yasi
de Ro Ro Diego and the new Jan Punter,
Roman Charlotte Bli Nico Barba Adam Hunt Pavlo Stass
Nele Bach me, Gary G Almansa Zal Ari and
YPJ Barboza Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Broner Douglas
Fry Franca, Bela Gil Cortes Solis Scott Zachary ftdw
Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio, Luke Loki, Georgio
Theophano Chris Williams and Peter Wo David Williams, the
Ausa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie Martinez,
Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Larry Dey Junior, Old Einon Starry
Michael Bailey. Then Spur by Robert Grassy Zorn, Jeff
mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radick, Mark Kempel, Thomas Dvor
Luke Neeson, Chris Tory Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert Jessica.
No week in the B brand Nicholas Carlson Ismael
Bensley Man, George Katis, Valentine Steinman, Perros, Kate Von
Goler, Alexander Albert Liam Dan Biar Masoud Ali Mohammadi
Perpendicular J Ner Urla. Good enough, Gregory Hastings David
Pins of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos Net.
A special thanks to my producers is our web,
Jim Frank Luca Toni, Tom Ween, Bernard N Cortes
Dixon, Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble Catherine and Patrick Tobin,
John Carl, Negro, Nick Ortiz and Nick Golden. And
to my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Si, Adrian Bogdan
Knits and Rosie. Thank you for all.